-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers. This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well tonight.
And now we're gonna get to the news.
According to a new poll, President Biden's
approval rating is 45%, which, if you've seen his past numbers,
pretty much counts as beloved.
[ Laughter ]
To the Biden camp, this is like Paul Rudd numbers.
President Biden held a 79-minute video conference yesterday
with British Prime Minister Boris Johnson,
French President Emmanuel Macron,
and German Chancellor Olaf Scholz.
A discussion between four white guys about world affairs,
or, as it's more commonly known, a podcast.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today announced a ban on the importing
of Russian oil, natural gas, and coal.
Honestly, I'm surprised Russia sends us any fuel,
since they can't even get it to their tanks.
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Laughter ]
Ya Burnt?
Amid threats from Russian assassins,
Ukrainian President Volodymyr Zelenskyy last night
revealed his location in a video on social media
and said quote, "I'm not hiding."
Dude, I salute your courage, but it's fine if you hide.
[ Laughter ]
It's a war, not WWE.
[As Hulk Hogan] "I'm right here, brother!
Any time, any place!"
[ Laughter ]
Senate Minority Leader Mitch McConnell
is reportedly opposed to a provision
in the new federal spending bill
that allows schools to serve free meals to students.
And this is weird -- he also announced plans
to go down to the local school
and eat a big sandwich in front of the kids.
[As McConnell] "Yum, yum. So good.
Bet you'd like a bite of this." [ Chortles ]
[ Laughter ]
CDC director Dr. Rochelle Walensky
said in a recent interview that the coronavirus
will probably be a seasonal flu.
Okay, but is it gonna be regular seasons
or, like, seasons of "The Voice"?
'Cause they have like nine seasons a year.
A team of former Biden COVID advisers and outside experts
yesterday released 250 recommendations
to further combat the coronavirus.
Alright, but remember,
we couldn't even get people to follow one, so...
A man was arrested in Ireland yesterday
after he reversed a truck through the gates
of the Russian embassy and said that he di-did it --
[ Laughs ] Did-did-diddit.
♪ Dit-dit-dit-dit ♪
Don't remix the jokes live.
♪ Did-dit-dit-dit-dit-dit ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah. Oh, no, no, no. No, no, no, no, no.
We talked about this.
A man -- Yeah, we're gonna go back to the beginning, Wally.
I don't think they remember.
I'm gonna try to refocus the blame on Wally.
[ Wally laughing ]
A man was arrested in Ireland yesterday after he reversed
a truck through the gates of the Russian embassy
and said that he did it because of Russia's invasion of Ukraine,
adding, "And also, whiskey."
[ Laughter ]
Hard to bust a guy for being drunk
when I'm the guy who did-did-diddit.
[ Laughter ]
The average U.S. price for a gallon of regular gasoline
yesterday hit an all-time high.
But good news -- Dollar General
has a great deal on irregular gasoline.
[ Laughter ]
New Jersey Governor Phil Murphy yesterday
lifted the statewide public health emergency
which had been in place since --
I'm guessing the Industrial Revolution?
[ Laughter ]
The makers of Mountain Dew recently announced
its new so-called "Legend" flavor,
which appears pitch black
and tastes like blackberry, citrus, and ginger.
As opposed to regular Mountain Dew,
which is yellow and tastes like yellow.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, today was National Proofreading Day,
but apparently no one told the NBC Store!
[ Laughter ]
I don't want -- I don't want this
to seem like a judgment on you guys.
It took a little bit long for you to get to the reading joke.
[ Laughter ]
"'Late.' That's good.
Well, 'Night.' That's the way you spell that.
Uh..."
-[ Laughter ] -"'With.'
That's definitely how you spell 'with.'
Well, bear with me. I'll get it."
[ Mimics audience laughter ]
You guys, that was the monologue.
I'm sorry we put reading in there. That's...